HAVING BOTH OF YOU HERE WITH
YOUR EXPERIENCE AND EXPERTISE,
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL BE CHARGED
WITH A CRIME.
NOW FIRST, TY, LET ME START WITH
YOU HERE.
YOU SEE TWO CRIMINAL CHARGES FOR
SURE, AND MAYBE FOUR, RIGHT?
>> WELL, I'VE ALMOST LOST COUNT.
THERE IS THE CRIME OF DEFRAUDING
THE UNITED STATES, CRIME OF
PRESSURING OFFICIALS TO VIOLATE
THEIR DUTY, THERE IS THE CRIME
OF CORRUPTLY IMPEDING AN
OFFICIAL PROCEEDING.
THERE IS THE CRIME OF ASSISTING
AN INSURRECTION.
THERE IS THE CRIME OF INSPIRING
TO OVERTURN A FAIR ELECTION AND
TO OVERTURN THE GOVERNMENT,
THERE IS THE CRIME OF SEDITIOUS
CONSPIRACY.
EACH OF THEM IS BACKED UP BY
CONSIDERABLE EVIDENCE.
HOW MANY FEDERAL CRIMES DO YOU
NEED BEFORE WE HAVE TO REALLY
MOVE QUICKLY BECAUSE THE CLOCK
IS TICKING.
>> PROFESSOR, DO YOU BELIEVE --
THIS IS CRUCIAL BECAUSE I WANT
TO -- I KNOW THAT TIA DEGREES
WITH YOU ON PART OF THIS BUT NOT
ALL.
AIDING AND ABETTING AN
INSURRECTION AND SEDITIOUS
CONSPIRACY, THESE CHARGES, DO
THEY HAVE ENOUGH?
HAVE THEY PROVED THAT TO A
CRIMINAL DEGREE AND TO PUT THAT
ON THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
PROFESSOR TRIBE?
>> I THINK THE ODDS ARE THE
EVIDENCE IS THERE.
WE'VE SEEN A GOOD BIT OF IT, BUT
IT'S ONLY THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG
WE'VE SEEN.
WE'VE HEARD CASSIDY HUTCHINSON,
WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF THE
PRESIDENT'S PHONE CALLS.
WE'VE HEARD EVIDENCE ABOUT WHAT
THOSE PHONE CALLS WERE TRYING TO
GET CLARK TO TURN THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE TO DO THE PRESIDENT'S
BIDDING.
>> YEAH.
>> WE KNOW THAT THERE WAS A
PHONE CALL TO RAFFENSPERGER GET
HIM TO, QUOTE, FIND, UNQUOTE,
11,780 VOTES.
WHEN YOU ADD IT ALL UP, SINCE WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT WE DON'T KNOW,
THAT IS, WE DON'T KNOW ALL THE
REMAINING EVIDENCE, I CAN'T SAY
THE DAY AFTER TOMORROW THERE IS
ENOUGH TO INDICT, BUT I CAN SAY
THE TRAJECTORY IS CLEAR.
THE ODDS THAT THERE SHOULD NOT
BE AN INDICTMENT BEFORE THE END
OF THE YEAR, AN INDICTMENT THAT
CAN THEN HAVE A SUPERSEDING
INDICTMENT ARE VANISHINGLY LOW.
>> SO, TY, WOULD YOU AGREE WITH
THAT?
AND WHERE DO YOU SEE THE CHARGES
RIGHT NOW THAT THEY HAVE?
TY, I'M VERY CURIOUS BECAUSE I
THINK PEOPLE ARE VERY FOCUSED ON
THE AIDING AND ABETTING
INSURRECTION AND SEDITIOUS
CONSPIRACY CHARGES.
WOULD YOU GO AS FAR AS PROFESSOR
TRIBE ON THAT?
>> NO, BUT I AM WITH HIM.
I THINK -- SO AS A FORMER LINE
PROSECUTOR AND CHIEF OF A
CRIMINAL DIVISION IN THE U.S.
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE, THERE ARE
MULTIPLE APPROACHES TO INDICT.
SOME PEOPLE WANT TO CHARGE
MULTIPLE COUNTS.
SOME PEOPLE WANT TO BE EFFICIENT
AND LET THE FACTS EASILY SOLVE
THE ELEMENTS OF A CRIME.
I THINK THE NON-RECKLESS WAY TO
CHARGE THIS ON THE APPARENT
EVIDENCE IS THE CONSPIRACY
COUNT, WHICH I FAVOR BECAUSE IT
WOULD BRING IN OTHERS CULPABLE
AND IT WOULD ALSO LEVERAGE THE
ABILITY OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO IMPRESS UPON
OTHERS THE IMPORTANCE OF
COOPERATING IN SOME FASHION TO
GET THEIR TRUTHFUL TESTIMONY.
I THINK -- I THINK THE
CONSPIRACY TO DEFRAUD THE UNITED
STATES IS THERE IN MANY, MANY
PIECES.
I THINK PICKING THE ONES --
PICKING THE PIECES THAT BEST
FALL TOGETHER IS A CHORE THAT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS MORE
THAN CAPABLE OF.
I ALSO AGREE ON THE OBSTRUCTION
OF AN OFFICIAL PROCEEDING.
INSTRUCT, INFLUENCE OR IMPEDE AN
OFFICIAL PROCEEDING.
I THINK THOSE CHARGES APPEAR
QUITE SIGNIFICANT IN TERMS OF
THE EVIDENCE.
I THINK THE CONVERSATION THAT
THE PROFESSOR JUST REFERRED TO
WITH RAFFENSPERGER IS HIGHLY
PROBATIVE.
I THINK THE FAKE ELECTOR EFFORTS
PARTICULARLY IN ARIZONA AND IN
GEORGIA ARE HIGHLY PROBLEMATIC.
I THINK THE PRESSURE ON PENCE IS
HIGHLY PROBLEMATIC AND THE
ENTIRE BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN
JEFFREY CLARK AND, YOU KNOW,
THE -- AND THE REQUEST THAT
TRUMP MADE OF ACTING ATTORNEY
GENERAL ROSEN AND HIS DEPUTY.
>> YEAH.
SO THE QUESTION IS, OF COURSE,
BOTH OF YOU LAYING THIS OUT, I
WANT TO EMPHASIZE TO EVERYBODY
IN THE VEN DIAGRAM WHAT YOU
AGREE ON.
LAWYERS CAN HAVE VERY DIFFERING
VIEWS.
MERRICK GARLAND IS GOING TO MAKE
THE DECISION, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, ON WHETHER WE DO THIS.
YOU'VE KNOWN HIM FOR MANY, MANY
YEARS.
HE UNDERSTANDS WHAT A CRUCIAL
DECISION THIS IS.
RIGHT?
IT'S A LEGAL DECISION.
IT WILL IMPACT THE WHOLE
COUNTRY.
WILL HE DO IT, PROFESSOR TRIBE?
>> BEFORE I GUESS WHETHER HE
WILL DO IT, IT'S VERY NOTABLE TY
COBB AND I AGREE ON SO MUCH.
HE WAS TRUMP'S DEFENSE LAWYER.
IT'S ALSO NOTABLE THERE ARE
SERIOUS CRIMES EVEN WITHOUT THE
FACT THAT DONALD TRUMP SAT THERE
WHILE THE MOB THAT HE KNEW TO BE
ARMED WAS AIMED AT THE CAPITOL
AND CALLED HIS VICE PRESIDENT A
COWARD.
AS TO WHAT MERRICK GARLAND WILL
DO, I'VE KNOWN HIM FOR 50 YEARS.
I KNOW HE'S A SERIOUS,
THOUGHTFUL PERSON.
I DON'T PRETEND TO READ HIS
MIND.
I WOULD BE AMAZED IF HE WAS
DELIBERATELY MISLEADING THE
EVIDENCE AND SAYING HE WOULD
FOLLOW THE EVIDENCE WHERE IT
LED.
HE WOULD NOT ALLOW POLITICS TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
HE WOULD NOT ALLOW THE FACT THAT
WE'RE IN A POLITICAL SEASON TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
ALL OF THAT HE'S BASICALLY
TELLING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT
IF THE EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT TRUMP
IS ALMOST CERTAINLY GUILTY, HE
WILL GO AFTER HIM.
THAT IS WHAT THE EVIDENCE SHOWS.
I DON'T THINK HE WAS BEING CUTE.
I DON'T THINK HE WAS WINKING AND
NODDING THE WAY DONALD TRUMP
MIGHT HAVE BEEN DOING WHEN HE
GOT THEM TO DO HIS BIDDING.
>> YET, TY, THE STAKES ARE SO
INCREDIBLY HIGH.
IF HE GOES AHEAD WITH A CHARGE,
HE NEEDS TO KNOW HE CAN WIN.
THIS IS WHERE TRUMP'S COMES IN.
WILL TRUMP'S DEFENSE THAT HE
BELIEVED THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN, WHICH IS WHAT HE KEEPS
SAYING.
YOU CAN'T BLAME ME, I BELIEVED
IT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS TRUE.
WILL THAT DEFENSE WORK, TY?
>> I DON'T -- I DON'T BELIEVE
SO.
I THINK THE EVIDENCE --
CERTAINLY THE EVIDENCE WHICH HAS
BEEN PRESENTED, OF COURSE,
WITHOUT CROSS EXAMINATION OR
CHALLENGE, BUT ASSUMING THAT THE
EVIDENCE IS AS PRESENTED,
THERE'S CONSIDERABLE EVIDENCE
OUT THERE THAT HIS OWN LEGAL
ADVISERS, INCLUDING EASTMAN ON
JANUARY 4th, ACKNOWLEDGED THAT,
YOU KNOW, THEY WERE ACTING ON A
FRIVOLOUS LEGAL FOOTING.
I THINK THAT'S VERY DAMAGING TO
SOMEBODY WHO WANTS TO ARGUE
WILLFUL BLINDNESS.
I ALSO THINK THAT WHILE TRUMP
WILL -- MAY ARGUE THAT DEFENSE,
I THINK HE'S MORE LIKELY TO USE
THE TRIAL IN AN EFFORT TO, YOU
KNOW, DEAL WITH HIS THEMES THAT,
YOU KNOW, HE'S ALL POWERFUL.
HE GOT CHEATED.
HE'S THE
IF I COULD MAKE ONE POINT IN
SOMETHING THE PROFESSOR SAID
WHICH I THINK IS SIGNIFICANT IS
THE FACT THAT THE PROFESSOR
POINTED TO WITH THE PENCE TWEET
DURING THE ALMOST THREE HOURS OF
TRUMP'S INACTIVITY FITS VERY,
VERY PERFECTLY INTO WHAT I THINK
SHOULD BE -- I THINK CONGRESS
HAS THE LANE HERE, I DON'T THINK
THAT LANE IS TELLING MERRICK
GARLAND WHAT TO DO OR PRETENDING
THAT THEY'RE LEADING HIM
ANYWHERE.
MERRICK'S CASE HAS BEEN MOVING
ALONG AT A PACE, JUST BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE A PRESS RELEASE
EVERYDAY AND HAVE GRAND JURY
RESTRAINTS AND LAWFUL RESTRAINTS
ON WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO SHARE,
DOESN'T MEAN THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
LONG AT IT.
OBVIOUSLY THEY PROSECUTED PEOPLE
WHO ACTUALLY WENT INTO THE
CAPITOL EN MASSE.
BUT THE PENCE TWEET COUPLED WITH
THE THREE HOUR OF INACTION, IN
MY VIEW, EASILY FITS INTO THE
DEFINITION OF GIVING AID AND
COMFORT TO THE INSURRECTIONISTS.
AND THAT IS THE STANDARD UNDER
ARTICLE 3 OF THE 14th AMENDMENT
WHICH CONGRESS HAS AT ITS
DISPOSAL.
AND I DON'T FOR THE LIFE OF ME
UNDERSTAND WHY INSTEAD OF
TELLING THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
WHAT TO DO THAT THEY AREN'T
ACTING ON THAT ALONE, BECAUSE IF
THEY HAVE A SENSE OF THE
CONGRESS THE PENALTY OF FINDING
TRUMP GUILTY OF GIVING AID AND
COMFORT TO AN INSURRECTIONIST IS
DISQUALIFICATION FROM OFFICE
FOREVER.
>> AND THAT, OF COURSE, WOULD
OBVIOUSLY BE VERY SIGNIFICANT AS
HE MADE IT CLEAR, AT LEAST AS OF
NOW, THAT HE INTENDS TO RUN
AGAIN.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR SUCH A
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION.